[Musique]
bonjour Marc fen bonjour hier il y a eu
les annonces du Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal et puis il y a la FNSEA les jeunes
agriculteurs la Confédération paysane
notalement qui appelle à poursuivre la
mobilisation qu'est-ce qui coince
qu'est-ce qui ne leur va pas non on va
essayer de de décliner de montrer ce que
sont les annonce d'abord c'est un
mouvement qui est un mouvement de grande
ampleur c'est sans doute un mouvement
très inédit dans le monde agricole
depuis des dizaines d'années qui est le
fruit de la sédimentation de de nombreux
scolaires donc on essaie de répondre par
un certain nombre de mesures d'urgence
et évidente on on y reviendra évidemment
on y reviendra mais ça veut dire que là
c'est pas à la hauteur de leurs attentes
mais ça dépend des territoires il y a
des territoires qui étaient plutôt sous
la contrainte de la maladie hémorragique
épisotique la MH et sur la question du
GNR d'autres posent des questions sur
les questions d'élevage donc l'idée
c'est quand même de répondre au fur et à
mesure à des questions et apporter des
réponses et puis il y a des réponses
très claires qui ont été apportées par
le Premier ministre aussi quand on parle
de simplification l'idée hier c'était
pas dégrainer les dizaines et dizaines
de mesures de simplification qu'on peut
faire donc c'est aussi au travail qu'on
va essayer et faire en sorte queon soit
bien no rendez-vous de la simplification
donc il est pas normal queb ces annonces
d'hier qu'est-ce que vous dites par
exemple à ceux qui disent comme la FNSEA
toutes nos revendications n'ont pas été
entend prè il il y a un mouvement qui a
commencé réellement il y a 8 jours euh
il y a on a rencontré les syndicats il y
a 4 jours ils ont fait des propositions
il y a 3 jours on y répond hier sur une
liste de 120 ou 140 revendication on a
donné les lignes d'intention en terme de
simplification vous doutez bien qu'on
peut pas répondre à tout sous ce délai
là en revanche ce que je leur dis c'est
que le travail et la philosophie étayé
parce que la philosophie c'est bien mais
il faut donner des exemples étayé par le
Premier ministre hier Gabriel Attal de
ce que vous nous voulons faire en terme
de simplification de ce que nous voulons
faire en terme de rémunération euh de ce
que nous voulons faire au niveau
européen euh il y a des premières
mesures qui sont annoncées elles sont
appelées à se décliner sur d'autres
sujets bien évidemment donc ça va
simpimplifier il y a une annonce à
laquelle vous avez enfin une mesure à
laquelle vous avez accédé elle était
très attendue par certains c'est
l'annulation de la hausse de la taxe sur
le gazol non routier à peine adopté déjà
abandonné c'est une reculade pas du tout
c'est c'était une mesure qui n'était pas
une mesure d'économie budgétaire puisque
il y avait une baisse de l'avantage
fiscal qui correspondait à peu près à 70
millions d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires par l'État lesquelles
recettes étaient reventilé dans d'autres
dispositifs fiscaux de quoi on s'est
rendu compte en conscience c'est que les
70 millions qui étaient prévus de d'être
ventilés sur le territoire ça se
reventilait pas bien sur les territoires
passçon pas de façon homogène et qu' y
avait des territoires qui étaient
fortement pénalisés alors qu'est-ce que
le premier ministre a décidé c'est de un
supprimer la disposition telle qu'elle
était prévue de parce que ça c'est pour
la mesure immédiate de de faire en sorte
que dès le mois de février les
agriculteurs soient payés d'une avance
sur ce dégrèvement qu'ils ont parce que
normalement ils sont remboursés
plusieurs mois voire une année après
avoir c'est la trésorerie qui revient là
c'est plus de 200 millions de
trésoreries et je je le redis parce que
ça peut-être été mal perçu c'est plus de
200 millions de trésoreries qui vont
revenir dans les cours de ferme comme on
dit ça permet aux agriculteurs de ne pas
faire des avances c'est quand même très
dommageable qu'on demande à agriculteurs
ou des agriculteurs soient obligés de
faire un prè court terme pour en attente
d'une avance qui devait leur être payé
et donc ça c'estes 200 millions d'euros
qui seront fait et puis mesures de
simplification et mesures de trésorerie
à partir du 1er juillet donc dans
l'attente du 1er juillet 200 millions
environ qui ront dans les cours de fer
la la une avance sur ce qu'on va leur
rembourser et à partir du 1er juillet on
va simplifier les choses c'estàd dire
que l'agriculteur la déduction sera au
pied de facture c'est-à-dire qu'il aura
plus besoin de demander il y a 20 % des
agriculteurs comment une réduction
immédiate mais non mais il y a 20 % des
agriculteurs qui ne demandaient pas le
remboursement donc ça c'est pas
seulement une avance de trésorerie c'est
des gens qui ne demandaient pas le
remboursement parce que la procédure
était trop compliquée donc c'est pour ça
que la simplification est utile et qui
désormais se verront d'office appliquer
le remboursement mais l'idée avance
recul tout de même c'était de mettre fin
à l'incitation à consommer des énergies
fossiles est-ce que le GNR c'est pas
l'illustration de la difficulté de
concilier environnement et agriculture
et là vous avez dû choisir finalement
non la trajectoire et d'ailleurs les
agriculteurs le disent et je n'ai pas
entendu les syndicats divers et variés
dire qu'il fallait renoncer à la
trajectoire de décarbonation mais la
décarbonation elle doit s'accompagner
d'alternative et si quelqu'un ose me
dire qu'il y a un tracteur électrique
aujourd'hui possible non et de des
mesures d'accompagnement et donc il faut
aussi savoir regarder des mesures dans
qu'elles sont acceptables ou pas non pas
seulement financièrement mais dans leur
philosophie je je pense que c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on continue à
travailler les ONG dites que disent que
c'est une manière de revenir un peu sur
les ambitions environnementales non mais
c'est ça ça n'avait aucun effet sur la
consommation ça venait juste grver la
compétitivité la mesure de
défiscalisation gasoelle elle existe à
peu près dans toute l'Europe d'ailleurs
vous voyez bien qu'en Allemagne le
mouvement il est parti de là
euh c'est une mesure de compétitivité ce
qu'on a besoin de retrouver par nos
mesures fiscales c'est des mesures de
compétitivité mais elle n'étaaient pas
incitative quand vous n'avez pas pas
d'alternative si vous dites je vous je
vous hausse la taxe ça vous fait pas
changer votre tracteur en revanche ça
vous fait une taxe supplémentaire donc
ça marche ce type de dispositif quand on
arrive à avoir des mesures de
compétitivité qui permettent de
substituer de la fiscalité on va revenir
sur les mesures de simplification
immédiate juste revenir sur un tout
petit mot que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez dit qu'il y aurait
d'autres annonces sur les revenus est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose en tête
précisment non non ce que j'ai dit sur
la question oui ce que j'ai d sur les
revenu c'est ce qu'on les mesures qu'on
fait sur la mesure la maladie
hémorragique épisotique c'est les
mesures que j'annoncerai la semaine
chaîne sur la viticulture puisque c'est
un secteur qui est très en crise avec
des mesures gestion de crise qui
permettront de couvrir à la fois les ce
qui s'est passé sur le Milu vous savez
la maladie qui est très apparu en
particulier dans le sud-ouest des
mesures de trésorerie pour les les
viticuteurs qui sont avec des prix très
bas conttenu d'un d'un surstock et puis
de travail qu'on a à faire sur à la fois
stockage et aussi sur l'arrachage
éventuellement différés vous avez
annoncé donc 10 mesures de
simplification immédiate alors c'est un
peu technique mais on va prendre un
exempleer prendre on va prendre un
exemple parce qu'il est absolument
éloquant c'est la règlementation sur les
ha il y a 14 règles qui se superposent
aujourd'hui il y en aura plus qu'une les
ha c'est le symbole de l'absurdité
française en matière d'AGC très
emblématique parce qu'au fond on a la
réglementation la plus sévère du monde
la plus encadrée du monde et ça n'a pas
empêcher la disparition des d'ailleurs
qu' ne sont pas imputables qu'à
l'agriculture d'ailleurs on dit souvent
ils ont été arrachés c'est pas qu'ells
ont été arrachés c'est qu'ells ont
disparu pourquoi parce que quand vous
avez 14 réglementations pour être
tranquille le mieux c'est de ne pas
avoir de Ha et avec les écologies je
crois que nous partageons la volonté
d'avoir plus de a c'est bon pour
l'agriculture c'est bon pour la
biodiversité c'est bon pour l'eau c'est
bon pour les sols enfin bref c'est bon
contre les inondations c'est bon pour
lutter contre l'érosion des sols mais au
bout il faut être en conscience à se
dire que la réglementation telle qu'elle
a été produite elle a abouti qu'à une
chose c'est à décourager les
agriculteurs d'avoir des donc il faut
qu'on les encourage par des mesures qui
sont prévues d'ailleurs à hauteur de 100
millions d'euros pour replter des mais
pour replter des faut pas avoir le
sentiment qu'on est à la menace de 14
réglementations dès qu'on fait un geste
sur une c'est ça qui est un élément il
me sembles très important c'est de dire
la réglementation elle vient servir une
politique publique si elle fait
l'inverse de ce qu'on veutah
interrogeons la réglementation et
simplifion mais la vie concrètement des
agriculteurs va changer avec ces
annonces elle sera vraiment plus simple
il y aura plus de dossier de 20 point à
Cha fois sur une réglementation pour
faire une réglementation qui soit la la
somme compliquée des 14 c'est pas non il
faut que ça soit plus simple faut que ça
soit plus lisible il faut pas que
comment dirais-je les réglementations se
contredisent on a besoin d'entretenir
les on les fait dans quelqu voyez c'est
ça qu'il faut faire et donc l'objectif
c'est une seule réglementation simplifié
elle-même Marc fen ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire on se retrouve dans un
instant juste après le le fil info de
Dian ferschit à
8h40 la loi immigration promulguée cette
nuit par Emmanuel Macron le texte dont
35 articles ont été retoqués totalement
ou partiellement par le Conseil
constitutionnel et publié au Journal
officiel la droite dénonce toujours un
holdup démocratique un coup d'État de
droit de la part des sages certains
barrages levés notamment en île-de-fance
d'autres toujours en cours en corz en
Gironde ou encore sur la 10 au niveau de
nior dans la Drome la 7 reste
entièrement fermé jusqu'à Avignon après
les annonces de Gabriel Atal les
syndicats des agriculteurs appellent à
poursuivre le mouvement le Premier
ministre a lui promis un sursaut
agricole 10 mesures de simplification et
l'abandon de la hausse de la taxe sur le
Gazole Non Routier la plus haute
juridiction de l'ONU appelle Israël a
empêché tout acte éventuel de génocide à
Gaza la Cour internationale de justice
estime également qu'Israël doit prendre
des mesures immédiates pour permettre à
l'aide d'entrer dans l'enclave
palestinienne la 19e journée de Ligue 1
de football elle s'est ouverte sur une
défaite de deè défaite de suite pour
Lyon battu 3 buts à de à domicile par
Rennes cet après-midi Nice recevra mes
et puis à 21h marseille-monaco les
Monégasques qui sont aux portes du
podium France Info le 830 France Info
Agathe lambr jeanréy Baudo toujours avec
Mar ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alim aire la loi égalim qui
vise à protéger la rémunération des
agriculteurs n'est pas respectée hier
Gabriel hatal a annoncé de lourdes
sanctions contre trois entreprises qui
ne jouent pas le jeu quelle sanction
précisément qui est concerné et est-ce
que vous pensez que ça aura vraiment
valeur d'exemple permettez juste de
rebondir sur la question de la
simplification j'entendais votre
collègue dire 10 mesures 10 mesures
c'est 10 premières mesures il y aura
bien d'autres mesures de simplification
je vous donner un deuxème exemple quand
même de contradiction nous avons des
dispositions légales qui obligent à
débroussailler des territoires pour
lutter contre les inondations et par
ailleurs vous avez sur ces mêmes
territoires des obligations qui visent à
préserver les écosystèmes et donc il
font qu'on empêche de débrousiller je
vais donner un exemple très concret dans
le Var il y a une tortue qui s'appelle
la tortue
d'Herman elle est très protégée et son
risque principal c'est l'IND c'est
l'incendie mais on ne peut pas
débroussailler parce que il y a un site
de production résultat des courses on
débroussaille pas et à la fin les
tortues sont incendiées parce que les
incendies progresse vous voyez la
contradiction alors que l'objectif c'est
bien de protéger un écosystème et pour
le protéger il faut qu'on puisse
débroussailler à quel moment notre
système il produit ce genre de chose Mar
sédimentation de dizaines d'années c'est
une folie hein quand vous réfléchissez
structurellement c'est une folie vous
pas arrivé hier au gouvernement c'est ça
ce que je veux dire d'une C non mais
c'est pas mais chacun doit faire son
examen de conscience mais ces deux
réglementations elles existaient avant
que nous soyons là ces deux là très
précisément exist avant mais il faut
qu'on qu'on tricote et qu'on détricote
toutes ces ces réglementations qui sont
contradictoires parce que voyez bien que
pour un agriculteur d'aller lui
expliquer qu'il faut qu'il protège et en
même temps qu'il peut pas protéger il y
a quelque chose qui moi je l'ai vu hein
sur un certain nombre de dialogue que
j'ai depuis des semaines et des mois
avec les agriculteurs c'est pas
complètement une surprise pour moi comme
vous le savez c'est un sentiment
d'incompréhension et au fond un
sentiment de mépris et c'est un chantier
qui est immense mais c'est un chantier
qui est immense c'est pour c'est de le
Premier ministre a dit par département
sur la ha dans la HauteGaronne il y
avait un arrêté supplémentaire par
rapport à la réglementation donc on
supprime l'arrêté qui est en hagaronne
d'abord il y a un travail départemental
au aux réglementation nationale vienent
s'ajouter des arrêtés départementaux
c'està-dire que le voisin de la du du
Tarn Garon il a pas la même règ que le
voisin de hautegaron et puis de il faut
faire un travail au niveau national sur
la et sur tout le reste en prenant en
ligne de compte quelle est la politique
publique qu' sert et pas de mettre les
agriculteurs face à des injonctions
contradictoires et je réponds maintenant
à votre question oui parceil y question
des agriculteurs alors c'est une partie
de la réponse sur la question du revenu
on a réuni hier avec Bruno Le Maire les
industriels les transformateurs et la
grande distribution d'abord vous dire
que j'ai on a on a secoué les choses
parce qu'on avait le sentiment que les
choses se passaient bien dans leurs
expressions et on leur a dit
manifestement ça se passe bien deuxième
chose on a entendu des gens qui ont dit
égalim les deux premières années deux
trois premières années ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné en particulier dans les
années de croissance inflationniste où
la matière première agricole a plutôt
été bien prise en compte on a à partir
des lois égalim luttter et empêcher un
phénomène qui est existé depuis 10 ans
et ça c'est depuis qu'on est arrivé
qu'on l'a fait c'était un phénomène de
déflation les prix agricoles ils avaient
baissé depuis 10 à 15 ans par égalim on
avait inversé mais depuis cette années
dans les négociations qui sont en cours
il y en des pratiques qui viennent
détourner égalim alors première pratique
de détournement c'est c'est je respecte
pas la loi c'està direire que je ne
tiens pas compte des matières premières
agricoles ceux qui ne respecteront pas
la loi c'est simple ils peuvent encourir
jusqu'à 2 % d'amende sur leur chiffre
d'affaires TR entreis les trois
entrepris ça c'est celles qui sont déjà
en cours mais on va cont c'est pas c'est
pas solde de tout compte il y a trois
entreprises effectivement qui vont d'ors
et déjà être sanctionné il m'appartient
pas d' d'en donner les noms parce que la
procédure est en cours et puis toutes
celles qui ne respecteront pas le
paiement de la matière première agricole
ils seront sanctionnés et ça peut aller
jusqu'à 2 % du chiffre d'affa parce que
les prix des agriculteurs ont baissé de
9 % quand les prix dans les supermarchés
sur les étal augmenté de 10 %. comment
c'est possible que que que le prix à la
production soit ensuite
multiplier mais c'est là qu'il a un
sujet de répartition de la marge c'est
là que chacun ce qu'on a dit hier doit
faire parce qu'on peut pas moi j'entends
beaucoup de gens qui font des grandes
déclarations d'amour sur l'agriculture
qui disent on aime la souveraineté on
aime les produits français on aime la
qualité tout ça est vrai en plus mais il
faut qu'il passe aux acte parce que la
chaîne alimentaire c'est ce que doit
faire l'état en terme de simplification
d'appui aux filières upè la valeur
ajoutée alors il y a des des travaux qui
sont en cours qui vont permettre de les
qui sont lancés déjà qui vont permettre
compris au Parlement ce sont les
industriels comme disent certains Rapp
c'est parfois les industriels c'est
parfois la grande distribution moi je
comprends pas par exemple que sur un
certain nombre de produits les produits
les plus qualitatifs les marges
manifestement mais ça nécessite d'être
documenté soit plus élevé que sur les
produits de base parce qu'évidemment ça
donne un avantage comparatif aux
produits qui sont avec des standards
moins exigeants et donc il y a quelque
chose d'un double discours qui est pas
possible donc des contrôles et puis il y
a un deuxième façon de dévoyer les
contrôles c'est d'aller mettre des
centrales d'achat ailleurs en Europe
pour essayer deéroger au droits français
le ministre Bruno Le ma a dit très
clairement et c'est pas acceptable et
donc on va faire en sorte que d'abord un
on voit s'il y a pas un détournement de
la loi ça c'est des grands noms de la
distribution qu'on connaît bien oui
qu'on connait bien ou je connais bien
oui je vous rappelle qu'il y a quelques
semaines j'ai eu quelques échanges
scripturaux si je peux dire au travers
de Twitter que parfois on me reproche
d'avoir tapé du point sur la table à
l'endroit effectivement de Monsieur
Leclerc moi j'ai pas envie de nouer des
des polémiques mais quand j'entends
quelqu'un dire si je trouve pas les
produits au prix que je veux j'irai les
chercher ailleurs je considère qu'il ne
fait pas un acte de souverain sur la
souveraineté alimentaire française et
c'est un acte de patriotisme agricole
alors que ça n'est pas l'image qu'il
véhicule oui oui mais peu importe que ça
soit il essaie chacun moi je répète j'ai
pas envie de rentrer dans une polémique
avec lui ça m'intéresse par ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la rémunération donc
les grandes déclarations ça suffit et
donc ceux qui ne jouent pas le jeu
seront sanctionnés et par ailleurs on
regardera précisément où réparti la
valeur ajoutée cette mesure sur la loi
égalim vous pensez que c'est une mesure
structurelle qui va faire que les
agriculteurs puissent enfin vivent
décemment de leur reven parce que
plusieurs syndicats disent que le compte
n'y est pas que que de façon pérenne
rien n'est fait pour s'assurer qu'ils
puissent vivre de leur travail
qu'sarrêent deente à perte sur faut
aussi qu'on arrive à convaincre
peut-être des filières toutes les
filières ne sont pas dans égaliment
parce qu'elles ont fait le choix en
conscience de dire on préfère avoir une
négociation d'une autre nature avec la
grande distribution peut-être qu'il faut
se poser la question de savoir s'il y a
pas besoin d'une contractualisation mais
Lesch que prop les insoumis par
exempleise je ne connais pas beaucoup de
filières qui disent il faut abroger
égalim les seulle personnes qui a
demandé abroger égalim c'est Monsieur
Leclerc reprenez ses déclarations à
l'époque en disant c'est on on est le
seul pays à faire ça c'est un pur
scandale on a plutôt intérêt à regarder
et à réfléchir au niveau européen et ça
me permettra de répondre à votre
question que de de de revenir sur
quelque chose qui permet d'encadrer les
marges et de d'encadrer la matière
première agricole de sorte qu'elle soit
payée après les propositions
démagogiques du genre on va fixer une
obligation de prix plancher comme on
peut le faire parce qu'il y a des règles
quand même européennes que sur les prix
agricoles français et qu'on peut pas le
faire sur les prix des autres pays
qu'est-ce que ça fait ça vient mettre en
concurrence déloyal les produits
agricoles français donc il faut que la
matière première elle soit payée au
paysans français comme elle doit être
payé aux autres agriculteurs et c'est
comme ça qu'on arrivera à le faire et
pas autrement vous dites que ce serait
contre-productif mais c'est
manifestement enfin c'est c'est
d'ailleurs à ce motif là qu'on en on l'a
pas accepté parce que s'il était aussi
simple que ça de dire moi je mets le
kilo de tomate à 2 € ou à 10 € en France
pour payer les agriculteurs et que
Larive de la tomate à 3 € vous croyez
qu'il va se passer quoi donc on a besoin
que les prix montent et que les prix
montent y compr pris au niveau national
et bloquer les marges des produits des
des de l'industrie agroalimentaire comme
le demande Jean-Luc mélch oui moi
j'entends beaucoup d'industrie
agroalimentaire c'est faire une mesure
c'est toujours des mesures une espèce de
mesure généraliste moi j'entends
beaucoup d'industries agroalimentaire
aussi qui dans la le sujet
inflationniste on ont des marches qui
sont réduites alors après qu' y a des
grands groupes qui doivent réfléchir et
faire leur examen sur quelles sont les
marches qui peuvent être accepté pour
faire en sorte que l'ensemble de la
filière oui mais j'entends beaucoup
d'entreprises j'ai plutôt des
témoignages d'entreprise sur les
territoire qui disent moi je suis pas
sûr de terminer l'année cont comp tenu
de la hausse des coûts la nécessité de
rémunérer la matière première et la
pression comme fait la grande
distribution il y a beaucoup de PME en
France il y a des très grands groupes
emblématiques mais il y a beaucoup de
PME qui ne passent pas la rampe comment
dirais-je de la négociation et qui sont
en risque économique vous parlez de la
concurrence européenne il a aussi une
concurrence internationale Gabriel Atal
a redit hier l'opposition de la France à
la signature du traité Mercosur qui est
un traité de libre échange avec
l'Amérique du Sud est-ce que vous
garantissez que cet accord de libre
échange entre l'Union Européenne
l'Argentine le Brésil l'Uruguay et le
Paraguay ne verra pas le jour le
président de la République s'est engagé
le Premier ministre l'a rappelé hier et
on peut pas n mais les négociations
Contin continu au niveau européen très
bien le président de la République s'est
engagé sur le fait que nous
n'accepterions pas ce traité du Mercosur
et nous faisons les pression nécessaire
sur qui il faut pour faire en sorte que
ce traité du Mercosur n'aboutisse pas
pourquoi parce qu'il met en situation de
concurrence très déloyal nos
agriculteurs et en plus sur beaucoup de
secteurs sur la volaille sur la viande
sur beaucoup de se c'est un un accord
qui dans des conditions par ailleurs de
production que nous n'avons pas en
France qui sont beaucoup plus comment
dirais-je libéral on va dire ça comme ça
et qui donc mett en difficulté
potentiellement si l'accord était donc
le président de la République a dit très
clairement les choses et il l'a redit
très clairement j'ajoute qu'il a demandé
à ce que soit mentionné à l'ordre du
jour ce qui était pas arrivé depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs en conseil des
ministres des chefs de gouvernement la
semaine prochaine ce point agricole et
ce point Mercosur et pourquoi dans ce
cas au Parlement européen votre groupe
renw a voté pour l'accord de libre
échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande qui lui
va faire arriver massivement des agneaux
du lait les écologistes le RN LFI le PS
il sont opposés il y a que votre groupe
qui a voté pour aujourd'hui vous nous
dites que vous êtes contre le ma non non
non mais parce que c'est pas aucun
accord et aucun commerce en France hein
50 % des céréales françaises et sort de
France euh l'excédent commercial
agroalimentaire c'est les vins
spiritueux vous voulez pas d'accords
internationaux par exemple typiquement
le blé il par plutôt au Maghreb il parle
pas forcément il parle pas forcément de
l'autre côté de la terre non mais il y a
a des il y a une géographie aussi de la
production la Nouvelle-Zélande alors on
a besoin de vérifier que ça ne mettra
pas mais il y a pas de concurrence parce
que déloyal au sens environnemental du
terme c'est le système le plus extensif
qu' soit ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
qu'on prenne des mesures pour retrouver
de la compétitivité en France parce que
le sujet c'est d'être compétitif si on
arrive à faire des céréales qui vont sur
les marchés internationaux on a des
règles en France on fait pas des
céréales de la même façon que les autres
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont de qualité
et elles sont stables en production en
volume et donc on a besoin d'abord de
retrouver de la compétitivité en France
et pas simplement de dire je jette tout
qui les nourriront parce que moi je n'ai
pas envie que ce soit monsieur ptine qui
nourr alors on continue cette discussion
dans un instant Mar F ministre de
l'Agriculture juste après le fil info de
Dian ferchit à
8h52 abandon de la hausse de la taxe sur
le gazolement routier indemnité gonflé
pour les éleveurs dont les bêtes sont
touché par la maladie hémorragique
sanction pour les industriels aussi qui
ne respectent pas la loi égalim ou
encore simplification des normes les
annonces du Premier ministre Gabriel
hatal pour tenter de calmer la colère
des agriculteurs et il matin plus de
barrage en Île-de-France mais ils se
poursuivent sur la 10 dans la Vienne la
7 dans la Drome ou encore la 63 près de
Bayonne la FNSEA la Coordination Rurale
ainsi que la conf la Confédération
paysane ont appelé à poursuivre le
mouvement après avoir réunit les préfets
hier en vue de son application la loi
immigration a été promulguée cette nuit
par Emmanuel Macron le texte final sans
les articles censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel Donald Trump dénonce une
condamnation ridicule le candidat à la
primaire républicaine ancien président
américain condamné à verser 83 millions
de dollars à une ancienne journaliste
pour l'avoir diffamé une affaire sur
fond d'accusation de viol dans les
années 90 Donald Trump va faire appel
France Danemark c'est l'affiche de la
finale de l'Euro de handbal demain en
Allemagne les français qualifiés après
avoir battu la Suède 34 à 30 hier soir
les Danois eux se sont imposés sur les
Allemands 29 à
26 France Info le 830 France
Agathe lambray jean-réy Baudeau Marc fen
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire il reste donc
plusieurs points de blocage en France
malgré vos annonces et cela fait plus
d'une semaine que les agriculteurs
bloquai les routes certains s'en sont
pris à des préfectures hier c'est le
bâtiment de la mutuelle sociale agricole
de Narbonne qui a été incendié pourquoi
tant de mensuétude avec eux est-ce que
ça va continuer dans les jours qui
viennent vous allez continuer à laisser
faire
commeétude il y a aucune ambigué sur le
fait que des violences tes que Cell qui
sont passés à Narbonne violence aux
personnes les violenceces au mi ne sont
pas acceptables donc je je dénonce des
actes qui sont minoritaires euh j'ai
nous étions hier avec le Premier
ministre sur un un point de blocage tout
à fait pacifique sans aucune dégradation
d'ailleurs ils ont tenu à nous le dire
euh distingons ce qui est une colare de
gens qui gagnent parfois qui travaillent
c'est quand même la seule profession qui
peut travailler 40 50 60 70 he et qui
accepte dont on accepte collectivement
qu'il puisse perdre de l'argent ou
gagner 200 € par mois donc ça peut
légitimement aussi provoquer des moments
de tension mais en tout cas il y a
quelque chose qui n'est pas acceptable
c'est la violence et donc la violence
elle est dénonçable dans tous les
domaines parce que sinon évidemment il y
aurait une distinction mais queil y ait
des points de tension avec des gens qui
sont dans cette situationl c'est normal
il y a pas une question deétude une
faveur parce que l'écologiste Yannick
jade par exemple disait que si euh les
verres faisaient le millième de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui ils seraiit en
prison soutenu des mouvements de gens
qui sont venus incendier des des des
carts de police siamment qui sont venus
tirer avec des mortiers en direction de
la tête ou du corps de policiers et de
gendarmes je voyez c'est c'est pas tout
à fait je pense du mouvement de Saint
Soline donc il y a quand même des choses
qui sont à distinguer parce que vous ne
voyez pas ça mais quand il y a un acte
de violence euh mais je sais que les
organisations syndical agrico sont
responsables quand il y a un acte de
violence vous me retrouverez toujours
pour le dénoncer mais distinguons ce qui
est une colère et un mouvement de colère
de ce qui est des actes de violence
délibéré il y a des gens qui sont mus
par simplement le désir d'en découdre
avec les forces de l'ordre c'est pas
c'est pas ce que je vois aujourd'hui sur
le terrain dans les mouvements agricoles
donc il y a un certain nombre de points
qui ont été débloqués il y a un certain
nombre de points qui sont encore bloqués
on va continuer à travailler et à dire
ce qu'on fait en terme de simplification
je j'ai oublié de les dire tout à
l'heure on va simplifier les normes
c'est quoi c'est les délais de de
recours sur les bâtiments d'élevage et
sur les projets d'eau on avait un régime
d'exception pour les agriculteurs
c'était 4 mois quand vous quand vous et
moi on dépose un permis de construire
c'est 2 mois le délai de recours
pourquoi cette exception agricole alors
que pour tous les autres le droit de
l'urbanisme qui s'appliquait c'était de
mois donc on va remettre dans le droit
commun un certain nombre de
réglementations c'est ce qu' a annoncé
le Premier ministre et je pense qu'au
fur et à mesure c'est de nature à à
libérer les points de nature à libérer
le point de blocage quand les
agriculteurs verront la réalité de ce
qu'il y a derrière les annonces qui sont
qui sont produites qui ne sont pas du
déclaratif qui sont du concret pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux dans beaucoup
de territoires et donc sur les points
euh sur le point de la violence il y a
pas de mensuétude il y a juste jamais de
mensuétude avec la violence mais quand
il y a un moment de tension et de colère
comme celui-là faut aussi savoir
l'entendre et les blocages donc vont
pouvoir continuer vous avez vu que la
colère est très profonde vous ne
craignez pas une AGR
des mouvements la CGT appelé à rejoindre
les oui alors vous avez vu la réponse
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre d'agricur
oui mais parce qu'il y a toujours dans
un certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales le d'aller chercher laa point
chez d'autres de de de de la colère et
du Grand Soir de la revendication mais
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui ont
dit qui viennent maintenant apporter
leur soutien aux agriculteurs qui ont
passé à longueur de temps sur les
plateaux télé leur temps à dire du mal
des agriculteurs à dire du mal de leur
pratique j'ai écouté hier j'ai pas envie
de rentrer en Curel avec eux mais un
certain nombre d'écologistes faire des
grandes déclarations d'amour quand tous
les jours ils ont demandé de la
réglementation de la réglementation de
l'interdiction de la contrainte au
niveau national comme au niveau européen
on n a pas parlé mais j'irai mercredi au
niveau européen pour débloquer un
certain nombre de sujets je pense au
sujet de la jacher et je pense que dans
la semaine on pourra avoir des réponses
et le président de la République qui
mettra tout son poids donc tous ces gens
qui maintenant viennent nous expliquer
qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on doit faire des
choses pour les agriculteurs et et et
pour qui le le dialogue et le discours
qu'ils ont eu vis-àis des agriculteurs
est un discours de dénigrement euh et de
je te montre du doigt comme pollueur
comme maltraitant tes animaux il y a
quelque chose quand même de curieux et
la manière dont l'extrême droite att
tenter ces derniers jours de reprendreou
Al l'O découvre pour une grande partie
d'entre
l'agriculture- ça c'est retombé un petit
peu oui j'ai l'impression parce que les
agriculteurs c'est des gens ils sont
durs à notre endroit nous gouvernant ils
sont durs aussi à l'endroit de ceux qui
veulent récupérer ceux qui veulent
récupérer pour faire l'agrégation et
ceux qui veulent récupérer le moment
parce que la rémunération c'est pas par
un coup de baguette magique c'est par
des actes concrets et Galim et le reste
reste euh la D la surtransposition
auquel il faut mettre fin et même faire
un mouvement inverse par rapport à un
certain nombre de sujets il faut le
faire donc cette cette volonté
permanente de récupération je trouve que
les agriculteurs c'est des gens qui sont
dignes et c'est des gens qui sont
respectueux et c'est des gens qui
n'aiment pas qu'on se moque d'eux et
donc le Yaka faucon des uns ou le Yaka
faucon des autres tout ça c'est une
démagogie qui ne résoudra pas les
problèmes et nous on souhaite résoudre
les problèmes et d'un mot vous avez
reporté votre loi sur le renouvellement
des générations un aveu du fait qu'elle
n'était pas à la hauteur face à cette
colère est-ce qu'il y aura de nouvelles
mesures est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
un mot
sur une grande partie était dans le
pacte et une partie était dans la loi on
va on va glisser un certain nombre de
mesures qui étaient dans le PCT dans la
loi ça permettra d'accélérer la
procédure premier élément et une grande
partie des mesures porteront autour des
questions de
souveraineté euh qu'on définisse
ensemble ce que c'est la souveraineté
pour que dans l'opinion publique on ait
un débat sur ce sujet de la souveraineté
c'est comment on on aboutisse à la
souveraineté et puis le deuxième sujet
c'est un certain nombre de mesure et
c'est dans les semaines qui viennent
hein le l'horizon puisque le Premier
ministre a dit dans les 3 semaines je
veux qu'on avance euh des mesures de
simplification à l'intérieur de cette
loi merci beaucoup Marc fen ministre de
l'Agriculture merci d'avoir été l'invité
du 830 France Info Agath lambray à
demain on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau point sur
l'information